foreign
[Music]
you will learn about kubernetes events
their use cases how to view them and how
to use them to troubleshoot a common
issue with Google kubernetes engine or
gke clusters let's get started by
understanding what kubernetes events are
kubernetes events are objects that give
insights about what's happening inside a
gka cluster they are usually generated
when a cluster's resources such as nodes
pods or containers change State these
events can be used to monitor your
application in cluster State respond to
failures and perform Diagnostics
remember events have a limited retention
time and will eventually be deleted so
you must monitor and collect events as
they happen kubernetes events can be
useful in multiple scenarios here are a
couple common use cases
pods not running within your cluster
viewing the kubernetes events for a pod
can reveal why it is not running leading
to a quick resolution for example you
may see image pullback off indicating
the cluster or node is unable to access
the repository where the container image
is hosted
a node in your cluster with a not ready
status viewing the kubernetes events can
indicate why the node is not ready for
example a node might have disk pressure
indicating that the underlying node is
running out of disk space kubernetes
events can be viewed in three different
ways with a gke cluster in the
kubernetes engine Council login Council
and within the terminal using Coupe
cuddle
before you can view the kubernetes
events ensure that users are granted
with the appropriate identity and access
management or IAM roles
viewing events using the kubernetes
engine Council requires the following
IAM roles kubernetes engine viewer
kubernetes engine cluster viewer and
logging logsviewer
viewing events using the logging console
requires only the following IAM roles
logging logs viewer
to view kubernetes events in the
terminal using Cube cuddle your
credentials must have at least the
default cluster role view or a cluster
role that allows access to the resource
events and the ability to call get list
and watch
let's now look ahead of you kubernetes
events within Google Cloud you can view
events across all levels of the
kubernetes hierarchy including cluster
nodes and workloads remember for
kubernetes clusters events are only
available for about 60 minutes
for gke events are exported and are
available using the Locking Council next
you can view kubernetes events in Cloud
logging with the following query log
underscore ID and brackets quotes events
and
resource.label.cluster underscore name
equals and your cluster name
finally you can view kubernetes events
from Kube cuddle by running Coupe cuddle
events Dash capital a or for specific
resource Coupe cuddle events-4 the
resource forward slash the resource name
for example Coupe cuddle events-4 pod
forward slash Ubuntu another useful way
to view events is with the describe
command for a specific resource for
example Coupe cuddle describe pod Ubuntu
the kubernetes events for the specific
resource are included at the bottom of
the output
let's dive into a demo and check out how
to use kubernetes events for
troubleshooting a common issue in the
gke cluster this cluster has a number of
workloads running but there appears to
be one workload with no pods running
let's get the kubernetes events for the
pod in this deployment by running the
following command
Coupe cuddle events dash n KH events-4
the Pod forward slash and the Pod name
oh it looks like there's insufficient
memory in the cluster for the bot to be
scheduled the solution here is the scale
up so let's add more nodes
now that the additional notes are ready
let's check the status of the workload
hmm events deployment workload still has
no pods running let's view the events
again
the pods are unscheduled as they could
not meet the taint and Toleration
requirement to be scheduled on the new
node let's add the Toleration to the
workload
success all the pods in the workload are
running
this is just one scenario where
kubernetes events assisted Us in quickly
identifying and resolving our issue of a
deployment not running
the next time you see a problem with
your cluster try using kubernetes events
to identify and resolve issues
for more details about kubernetes events
check out the following documentation
thanks for watching
[Music]